mmm sangria this wine is to die for what
is the secret my handmaiden accidentally
dropped a bunch of chopped apples into
the barrel delicious I think it's
absolute piss well I have been meaning
to tell you this morning I had a bit of
fun with my stepdaughter Jennifer yeah
oh I'd love to hear about having a
terrible time connecting with Britannia
then you will love this I woke up very
early this morning I snuck into her room
and I shrunk all of her wardrobe so that
she thinks she's gaining weight then I
barricaded her in her room and filled it
with mice and now they're her only
friends and that works
oh yes she actually confides in the mice
quite a bit he hasn't called to Mina
Portland I mean do you think I should
call to him where's that two poems oh
dear
that reminds me I did the most
delightful thing with my stepdaughter
serenity just yesterday oh please do
tell I took her on a trip to the forest
we had a lovely picnic then I drugged
her dropped her in remote location puts
gobs of honey and let her fend off the
bear what did you do to your
stepdaughter I hope it was fantastically
twisted yes it was I hmm good morning
sweet angel I brought you breakfast go
away good afternoon delicate flower
I brought you a puppy not my life how
you'd enjoy a late-night snack burn in
hell demon woman wicked wicked things
like poison and forced betrothal Dale
all of it well done you keep her in line
hmm I'll finish Patania is going to love
these and they're going to keep her
little food so nice and warm and by that
I mean horribly freezing cold all the
time just as I suspected
don't worry I'll put a spell on them so
Victoria you for having us I'm horribly
wicked I promise I guess the scarf is
off the table
it matches its heather gray
you